hopefully you saw the roundtable
discussion that happened around x-men
days of future past but you know what I
felt like you spent that whole time
defending the movie and not actually
getting to say what it was I actually
really liked about the movie I felt like
I never got a real chance to review it
so that's what I'm gonna do right now
what can I say guys it's awesome I know
these two guys argue with me saying yeah
I wasn't that good enough I'm sorry it's
awesome it's dealing with a premise that
is not an easy thing to pull off well
anytime you're dealing with time travel
and and anything will they do it seems
easy cuz movies and stories that do it
well make it seem effortless but it's
really easy to screw up and just make
confusing and go wait what is going on
this movie never does that you can
follow really easily which in and of
itself big accomplishment especially
considering that's not even straight
time travel they're actually sending
Wolverine back along his own timeline so
he's not really back in time he's
actually in his younger body with his
older mind still somewhat connected to
the future that he's trying to prevent
in the first place again could be really
complicated it could be impossible to
follow but it's not it's spot-on I think
this movie and a lot of ways really
cements the Bryan Singer when he works
needs to be working with ensembles and
think about it it's not just the x-men
movies that are good for his Valkyrie
had an ensemble the usual suspects
wasn't ensemble when he tries to make
things that are more focused on only a
couple of characters they tend not to
work as well and you get stuff like Jack
the giant slayer or Superman Returns
which you know again it's movie i think
is underrated but it's not one of his
better films I can't argue that it is
bryan singer is just really good at
balancing all the elements and giving in
my opinion just enough of these various
characters that you don't feel like
they're complete throw away and that's
true of returning characters as well as
brand new ones now this movie does
really kind of depend on you having seen
the first few not so much in terms of
plot you can follow the plot and what's
going on but you're not going to be
invested in a lot of the characters who
turn off unless you've been watching the
series up to this point especially in
the latter half i am going to be getting
a little bit into spoilers on these but
at this point if you really cared about
this movie you'd have seen it by now so
when you get characters like storm and
kitty pryde showing up or the fantastic
cameos that happen at the end
with Jean and Cyclops that stuff doesn't
have a lot of weight unless you've
watched the previous movie so you can
follow it if you haven't watched the
other movies but it's not gonna have a
lot of emotional weight because it
doesn't have time to fill you in on all
these people there's too much other
stuff going on and personally I'm okay
with that you know it's been a complaint
of a number of people that Hugh
Jackman's carrying this again again it's
Wolverine centric and I even zip myself
about first class it was very important
that Wolverine was not the center of
that story and now next movie they go
ahead and make in the center again but
you know what I'm okay with it because
they fundamentally changed his dynamic
he's actually filling a bit of the
professor x role because he's the one
who has a sense of what's going on he's
more of a mentor type the ones that are
actually going through a rough ER period
and are the ones actually going through
a personal journey our professor axe and
mystique and I would actually argue that
this is Professor X's movie more than
anybody else he's the one who's got the
furthest to travel because he's falling
the furthest since the last time we saw
him and it really dimension Eliza's
perfect strikes in the overall scheme of
things because when we've seen him as
Patrick Stewart who's always been
fantastic but he's just he's just very
stoic he's very wise he's he's got
everything together when we saw him in
first class he wasn't quite there yet
but you saw pretty through line to where
he was gonna be but now we see this he
had this middle ground where he just
completely dropped the bottom fell out
and his life was a mess and that just
adds a lot of dimension to him I really
had a lot of fun with the contrast of
magneto in terms of how he is in this
film and how we see him in the future
when he's like look all that stuff
didn't matter we just need to be
together and deal with this and just to
see the lengths that he was willing to
go to back in the 70s it's a fantastic
contrast and its really well-balanced
I'm not going to go through this element
by element but the effects are fantastic
the cast is fantastic a lot of the
characters that could have been
throwaways they're given performances
and just enough tiny little beats that
it works really well Quicksilver
completely steals the show and the other
thing that I really like is that this
one by the end feels very much like a
closure feels like a closed chapter
obviously we've got a post-credits scene
that sets up apocalypse which I'm
nervous about but I talked about that at
the round table but I really do love the
fact that this feels very much like the
closing of a book there's more that can
be told especially with the younger
versions of the cast but I like the
feeling of closure that this film has
and it's it's something nice and that it
doesn't be in it's something it doesn't
feel like we're getting a lot in comic
book movies anymore so that's another
added bonus for this thing for me as
well I'm not sure where it lands for me
in terms of overall ranking I think it
might be just barely behind first class
for me that's a really tight race though
x 2 is still my personal favorite but
it's it's right up there it does edge
out the Wolverine that does knock that
one out of third place I can't say that
much but you know I think it's a really
solid entry into the series that I think
a great way to close out kind of this
end of an era feel that that it brings
to the whole proceeding so i'll be back
to talk about this stuff when apocalypse
starts getting closer and I'm a talk
about it as as we find out more about it
because I'm excited by the fact that
Bryan Singer's doing it and I'm nervous
by the content but that's a discussion
for another time so until next time this
council is a jerk